Salut les Épicurieux !
Vous me posez beaucoup de questions
sur les réseaux sociaux et sur YouTube
avec le hashtag #DisJamy
et notamment sur les animaux.
Comme je suis très à cheval
sur le lien qui nous unit,
je les ai réunies
dans cette vidéo. C'est parti !
Une question de Christelle Jupin :
"Pourquoi les chats ronronnent ?"
Les scientifiques, Christelle,
n'ont pas encore percé
tous les mystères du ronronnement,
mais en général, si un chat ronronne,
c'est parce qu'il se sent bien.
Les chatons ronronnent
dès la première tétée et leurs mère aussi.
Ce sont souvent un signe de bien-être.
Étonnamment, les félins sauvages
ne semblent pas ronronner à l'âge adulte,
sauf les mères avec leurs petits.
Mais le chat domestique,
lui, aurait conservé ce caractère juvénile
comme moyen de communication
avec son maître.
Par exemple, lorsque le maître caresse
son chat, l'animal ronronne
pour signifier son bien-être,
pour dire continue à me caresser.
Le ronronnement n'est cependant pas
qu'un signe de bien-être.
Il participe, car il libère
chez le chat des endorphines,
un neurotransmetteur
messager du bonheur qui le détend.
Lors d'un examen vétérinaire par exemple,
ou face à un congénère agressif,
un chat peut donc aussi
se mettre à ronronner.
Pas par plaisir cette fois,
mais au contraire pour se rassurer.
Enfin, d'après certaines études,
les fréquences basses du ronronnement
auraient sur les eaux,
les muscles et les tendons des chats,
un pouvoir réparateur,
voire anti-douleurs.
Question de Clem :
"Pourquoi les papillons de nuit
sont-ils attirés par la lumière ?"
Parce qu'ils ont une vision
particulièrement adaptée
à la vie nocturne.
Leurs deux yeux captent mille fois plus
de lumière que ceux des papillons de jour.
Et c'est cette incroyable vision nocturne
qui leur permet de voler
en utilisant la Lune comme repère,
on parle d'orientation transversale.
En effet, en gardant un certain angle par
rapport aux rayons lumineux de la Lune,
ils n'ont aucun mal
à s'orienter dans le noir.
Ce que n'avaient pas prévu
les papillons de nuit, c'est que
le 27 janvier 1880, Thomas Edison déposerait
le brevet de l'ampoule à incandescence.
Grâce ou à cause de cette ampoule -
tout dépend de quel côté on se place,
Homme ou papillon de nuit -
les réseaux électriques se sont développés
à travers le monde et des centaines
de millions de petites Lunes
se sont mises à briller
encore plus fort
que notre satellite naturel, attirant
et déroutant les papillons
qui peuvent tourner pendant des heures
autour de ces sources lumineuses
artificielles et mourir d'épuisement.
" Pourquoi dit-on :
rusé comme un renard" ? C'est
une question de Yohan.
Saviez-vous qu'avant d'être reprise
par La Fontaine en 1668,
la fable "du corbeau et du renard"
avait déjà été écrite, notamment,
par Ésope, un fabuliste grec
plus de mille ans auparavant.
Comme quoi la réputation de cet animal
ne date pas d'hier
et ne se contente pas à nos régions.
Le renard est réputé
dans de nombreux pays.
Sa frimousse pleine de malice
et sa capacité à toujours trouver le moyen
d'entrer dans un poulailler
n'y sont sûrement pas pour rien.
En France, c'est "le Roman
de Renart" Renart avec un "T"
qui est à l'origine de l'expression :
"Rusé comme un renard".
Vous l'avez peut-être étudié à l'école,
en tout cas, moi, c'est ce que j'ai fait.
L'histoire est intéressante.
Il s'agit d'un recueil,
d'histoires animalières, écrit entre le XIIème
et le XIIIème siècle par plusieurs auteurs,
pas forcément connus d'ailleurs.
L'animal dont on parle aujourd'hui
et qui apparaît dans les récits
s'appelle à l'époque un "goupil".
Renart est alors un prénom utilisé
pour donner un titre au recueil.
Pourquoi "Renard" ?
Personne ne le sait vraiment.
Les aventures de ce goupil vont devenir
tellement populaires que le mot "renard"
va prendre la place du mot goupil
pour désigner ce petit mammifère.
C'est pas malin, ça ?
Maeva aimerait savoir pourquoi les chauves-
souris se tiennent la tête en bas.
Cette posture est naturelle
pour les chauves-souris.
Leurs pattes sont en effet trop faibles
pour supporter leur poids et les propulser
au moment de leur envol
en s'accrochant en hauteur, tête en bas,
il leur suffit au contraire de se laisser
tomber, de profiter de l'élan
de la chute pour déployer leurs ailes
et se mettre à voler,
puis leur tête en bas
a d'autres avantages.
Pendues à la voûte d'une
grotte ou à la charpente d'une grange,
elles se tiennent hors de portée
de certains prédateurs, comme les chats
ou les serpents.
Elles sont si bien
adaptées à cette posture
que quand elles se suspendent,
le poids de leur corps
tire sur les tendons
de leurs membres inférieurs, ce qui bloque
les griffes en position d'accrochage,
comme si elles étaient clipsées.
Cette position est tellement stable
que des chauves-souris
peuvent rester accrochées
même après leur mort.
Renversant non ?
Une question de Patrick :
" Que voient les chats
quand ils se voient dans un miroir ?"
On a fait plusieurs fois
le test du miroir avec des chats.
Le principe de cette
expérience scientifique,
mise au point dans les années 1970
par le psychologue américain
Gordon Gallup, est le suivant :
on place sur l'animal une petite marque,
une croix ou un disque de couleur
à un endroit bien visible,
sur son front par exemple.
Puis on installe l'animal devant un miroir
et on observe sa réaction.
S'il se frotte pour tenter
de faire disparaître cette marque,
cela signifie en principe
qu'il a compris que l'image
qu'il voit dans le miroir est la sienne.
Le but est de mesurer ainsi la perception
que les animaux ont d'eux-mêmes.
Si certaines espèces comme les chimpanzés
ou des grands mammifères
réussissent très bien ce test,
ce n'est pas le cas des chats.
Devant un miroir
un chat va tout au
plus montrer de la surprise
ou de la colère face à ce qu'il
va considérer comme un intrus,
tout comme il peut n'avoir
aucune réaction.
En tout cas, une chose est
sûre, il ne se voit pas, lui.
La question de Louis Picard :
"D'où vient l'expression : pleurer des larmes de crocodile ?"
Cette drôle d'expression remonterait
à une ancienne légende égyptienne
selon laquelle les crocodiles du Nil
attiraient leurs proies
en gémissant. Les imprudents
qui s'approchaient trop près
pour découvrir l'origine de ces plaintes
se faisaient alors dévorer.
D'où l'utilisation
de cette expression pour décrire
des larmes hypocrites,
un faux chagrin plein d'arrière pensées.
Mais au-delà de la légende,
cette expression renvoie aussi
à une vraie particularité des crocodiles.
Ils versent effectivement quelques larmes
lorsqu'ils mangent.
Si, si ! Même si les scientifiques
ne connaissent pas la cause exacte
de ce phénomène. Peut-être est-ce simplement
une façon de protéger leurs yeux.
À moins que ce ne soit provoqué
par les mouvements brusques
qu'ils font en mangeant.
Une chose est sûre, cela n'a rien à voir
avec un quelconque
remord ou chagrin envers leurs proies.
"Pourquoi les mouches ont-elles
un vol si erratique?"
C'est une question de Benoit P.
En clair, pourquoi volent-t-elles
dans tous les sens?
C'est vrai qu'on peut se poser la question
parce que dans la nature en plein air,
les mouches ont au contraire un vol
plutôt droit et dirigé.
Mais c'est vrai qu'entre quatre murs,
elles virevoltent et tournent sans arrêt,
parfois pendant des heures.
Et il y a une raison à cela. Pour voler,
les mouches ne peuvent s'appuyer
que sur ce qu'elles voient
et elles n'ont pas de radar,
contrairement aux chauve-souris, par exemple.
Elles vont donc plutôt se mettre à voler
en cercle, à tourner en rond
lorsqu'elles perçoivent
qu'elles sont dans un environnement clos,
une pièce carrée ou rectangulaire.
Tout simplement parce que c'est
la trajectoire la plus sûre
pour ne pas rencontrer d'obstacle.
Et oui, elles n'apprécient pas plus
que nous de se cogner aux murs.
Pas folle, la guêpe ! Euh... la mouche.
Retrouvez "C Jamy" du lundi au vendredi à 16h55
sur France 5 ou dès
maintenant sur France.tv.
Le lien est sous cette vidéo
et surtout, n'hésitez pas à vous abonner
et à activer la cloche. Faites-le savoir !